hello everybody how are you new day new
update sorry that this one comes a bit
later today but I was very busy this
morning I just got home I had a quick
look at the chart for 30 minutes and I
want to tell you what is going on here
for Bitcoin okay so if you remember
yesterday's video we're talking about
this Zone we're talking about the
scenario of a potential bounce but we
didn't like it much because we didn't
see enough strength in Bitcoin enough
sickness for Bitcoin to bounce of this
Zone we were expecting them to see more
of this type of weeks around this area
to be able to open up long position
comfortably to this Zone and we were
saying that Bitcoin was looking pretty
heavy so then we focused on this other
scenario that match with the
liquidation's hit map on high block and
remember that it was to lose support and
come back to this range let's go to the
photo time frame to this range that we
had here for 10 days okay this range let
me
show you yeah we had a range here
for 10 days so
we were expecting Bitcoin then if we
couldn't see those weeks in the one hour
time frame to drop below support and
come back to this range okay where price
Consolidated for 10 days okay let me
remove this again
it hasn't got there yet but or main
target is this one the 50 of this week
in the four hour time frame are 27
485 dollars Okay so
thus is still or Target we're gonna go
in a minute to the liquidation heat Maps
but remember we were talking that we
would see Bitcoin dropping we would see
some
range and then we were having the next
leg down let's go to the one hour time
frame so you can see more clearly
now what I'm anticipating is that
through the weekend we might see some
kind of sideways move we are usually
seeing that on weekends because there is
not that much liquidity because the
financial districts Forex uh the stock
market they are closed on weekends so we
don't have that usual liquidity from the
institutions that can move the market
what I'm gonna pay attention through the
weekend is going to be the 50 EMA in the
one hour time frame and what I'm
anticipating is that Bitcoin range
through the weekend and leaves time the
50 EMA
to come lower okay maybe Bitcoin can
retest it or maybe next week we can see
this target getting hit so that's pretty
much everything that I see for Bitcoin
now I want to check the liquidation's
hit map to see if they back up this
Theory let's go there
Capital let's go to the one move time
frame that I think it's showing the
liquidations pretty clear
okay let's get up this Zone
and yes you can see that the liquidity
is still there at 27 400 that's exactly
the 50 of the week and then around 27
100 which I assume is the the full week
the 100 percent
now I'm gonna go back to yesterday's
video because I'm pretty sure that the
liquidations have increased since
yesterday
which would make sense because many
Traders are probably trying to catch the
bottom and trying to catch a fallen
knife and therefore their long
liquidations are below so it could make
sense but yes guys this is a lot of
liquidity okay you can see here 28
billion 50 million 14 million 19
billions 16 billions there is a lot of
liquidity in this Zone
um I really think that this liquidation
so I'm gonna get heat sooner or later
I'm anticipating next week that's my
opinion obviously we're gonna see what
the weekend brings us
um the start of the next week for
to me seems very clear that next week we
will see these levels getting hit but
again non-financial advice to guys do it
yourself do what you want
um we'll see what happens now I want to
go back to the to the charts let's check
what the SMP is doing
oh wow the SMP is playing with fire you
can see how it doesn't really want to
get inside the box and yesterday is at
the end of the session a hit the top of
the box and then he bounced and today
the same thing happened but let's go to
the photo time frame let's see what's
happening in more detail
what I see here is that the price is
just coming down it's making a lot more
highs and lower lows and I think
eventually it's going to come all the
way to this book which is the
4100 Zone
then if it goes there just confirm that
the SMP is in a sideways move after a
very bullish move from here you can see
because to me this will be sideways let
me show you very clearly
this is to me this will be sideways and
then
at the 4100
I would like to see a reaction okay I
would like to see a bounce because if it
breaks below this Zone then I think I'm
gonna go all the way to probably the 4
000 Zone okay so that's pretty much
everything that I see with SMP it's
fighting for its life to not go into the
box but let's see what the next week
brings us
I want to end this video with Bitcoin do
you guys know the game right
be careful during the weekends because
there is not much liquidity so there are
a lot of traps a lot of fake outs wigs
that can stop you that's why you don't
suggest trading on weekends if you run
on training weekends maybe go for
altcoins that have more volatility you
might have some more fun I'll be paying
attention to that 50 EMA in the one hour
time frame I think Bitcoin might test it
over the weekend but I don't trade big
another weekend so there isn't going to
be any Bitcoin updates on Saturday or
Sunday
maybe I bring as soon they update the
soon update is definitely going to be
posted on Twitter as usual
but maybe I bring it to YouTube too that
depends on you on the number of support
likes comments let's see how you feel
about it okay let me know and also I'm
planning to upload a video maybe
tomorrow on Saturday about the bonds
Market about the two Jr deals chart it's
pumping why
that's an interesting one so that's
pretty much everything guys have fun
very nice weekend relax enjoy your loved
ones and I'll see you soon